hey this is presh talwalkar
consider a glass that has four balls
inside of it
the glass has an inner diameter of 10
centimeters and an inner height of 10
centimeters
each of the four balls has a diameter of
5 centimeters
how much water do you need to exactly
cover to the top of the balls
you can assume the glass is a right
cylinder the four balls are identical
perfect spheres and that the top two
balls are placed at a 90 degree angle to
the bottom two balls
i want to give a huge thanks to stephen
lauranges for solving this problem
when i attempted it i got the wrong
answer and i only learned
what i did wrong by reading stephen's
solution write up
i also thank zack and tomas for
independently sending me this problem
so apparently it's a very popular meme
and it turns out to be a very tricky
geometry problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so one way to approach this problem is
to consider looking from the very top of
the glass
what would you see
well from the top you would see the
border of the glass as a perfect circle
the two spheres in the top layer
their border would appear as two perfect
circles that are tangent to each other
and tangent to the glass
the spheres in the bottom layer
would appear to be the same except the
rotated 90 degrees and some of the
circle may be covered up by the spheres
in the top layer
but if we had x-ray vision the border of
the bottom spheres would look like
perfect circles that are tangent to each
other and tangent to the glass
so now let's consider the centers of
these circles
the diameter of each sphere
is 5.
so that will be true of the spheres in
the bottom layer and the top layer
therefore the radius of each sphere is
2.5
from this diagram we can then consider
the horizontal distance between the
center of the sphere in the top layer
and the center of a sphere in the bottom
layer we have a right triangle where
each side is 2.5 therefore the
hypotenuse will be 2.5 times the square
root of 2.
so we've deduced
that 2.5 times the square root of 2 is
the horizontal distance between the
centers of a top and bottom sphere
we'll now consider
a right triangle with the following
sides
we'll connect the hypotenuse
as the centers of a bottom sphere and a
top sphere
this will have a length of two times the
radius of the sphere which is five
because the spheres are tangent to each
other
next the other leg will be the
horizontal distance between the centers
and the third side will be the vertical
distance between the centers and this
will be what's allowing us to figure out
how tall all of these four balls are in
the glass
so we end up with a right triangle
that's like this it connects the centers
of two spheres and we have the
horizontal and vertical distance
so we already know that the hypotenuse
is equal to 5.
we just figured out the horizontal
distance is 2.5 times the square root of
2 and therefore the remaining side will
also be 2.5 times the square root of 2.
so now
we figured out 2.5 times the square root
of 2 is also the vertical distance
between the centers of a top and bottom
sphere
so we can now figure out how high the
four balls are in the glass
if we look from the side
we'll end up with a sphere on the bottom
layer and then we'll have two spheres on
the top layer as follows and we want to
know how tall are these spheres from the
bottom of the glass to the top of the
glass
so we know each sphere has a radius of
2.5
so that'll give us some indication of
the vertical distance and we then
figured out the tricky part which is the
vertical distance between
the center of the sphere in one layer to
the center of the sphere and the other
layer and that's 2.5 times the square
root of 2.
so the total vertical distance will be
the sum of all these lengths which will
be 5 plus 2.5 times the square root of
2.
we can now proceed to figure out how
much water we need
to fill to the top of these four balls
so consider a cylinder that goes from
the bottom of the glass
all the way to the top of these four
balls
the water that will be needed to fill to
this top will be the volume of this
cylinder to cover all these balls minus
the volume of the four balls
the volume of cylinder is pi times its
radius squared times its height
each sphere has a volume of four thirds
pi r cubed and then we multiply that by
four because there are four balls
the cylinder has a radius of 5
and a height of 5 plus 2.5 times the
square root of 2.
the sphere each has a radius of 2.5
so we can substitute in these parameters
and then we can simplify for the answer
which is 125 pi over six times the
quantity two plus three times the square
root of two and this is approximately
four hundred and eight
point
cubic centimeters
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
linked in the video description
and you can support me on patreon
you can also catch me on social media
either at mind your decisions or at
presh tallwalker